- Hey what's up y'all,
(upbeat music)
I'm here with Zachary Quinto,
and on the line from Northern
Ireland is Anya Taylor-Joy,
give it up.
(audience cheers and claps)
All right, so my next guest is a member
of one of the all time
great country groups y'all.
I love them.
Little Big Town.
She's also an author whose
children's book is called
"A Dolly for Christmas", here it is,
you can buy it today, and you should.
Please welcome Kimberly Schlapman y'all.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheers and claps)
(Kelly laughs)
(Kimberly laughs)
It was a walk-by, I like it.
Oh my, you--
(Kimberly speaks indistinctly)
You always look so beautiful.
You're such a light Kimberly.
- Oh, Kelly, you are a light.
You are a light.
The first time I met you,
I was like, this woman
is different and amazing.
- Oh my god,
(audience awes)
well ditto, ditto.
And you just, every time you
come on screen (Kelly laughs),
I'm like good lord.
Well say hi to Zachary and Anya.
- Hey there, how are you?
- Hey Zachary, hey Anya,
Great to meet you.
- Hi.
- it's been so much
fun to watch you y'all.
I've been sitting here in my kitchen
watching y'all.
It's interesting.
- (laughs) Welcome to 2020.
Well I want to talk about your new book.
It's about your adoption of Dolly, right?
- Yeah.
It's about our family's story
and what all we went through,
the infertility and the, just the years
of working so hard and so many prayers
that went up to God to
bring us another baby,
and it's our story of Dolly,
- Yeah.
- who came right at Christmas time.
Daisy, my older daughter,
literally prayed for a baby
for five years.
Every night, she prayed for a baby.
And then, she also asked Santa
Claus for a baby one year,
and then that year, I think God
and Santa Claus got together,
and Dolly Grace came, and it
was just the greatest miracle.
- Oh my gosh.
(audience claps)
Why did you decide to adopt,
and what was that journey like?
Tell us what that was like.
- Well, we went through
some rounds of in vitro.
Well, for years, we just tried naturally
to get pregnant again
after we had little Daisy,
and that never worked out.
And we had some heartbreak
in there, miscarriage.
And then we did two rounds of in vitro.
And you know, all the
things that go with that.
And there are just so many women out there
who are doing that now,
and bless you for that.
But after many years of failure
at that and loss, losses,
we decided, well, I always to adopt.
My husband and I both did.
So we thought, you know
what, I think it's time.
I think it's time we start
that adoption process.
So we did, and then,
now we know what we were waiting for.
We were waiting for little Dolly.
And it's so, was worth the wait.
- So what was it like to hold
Dolly for the first time?
I mean, all that time waiting, you know,
for your little one, and then finally.
- Well there's something,
I never told anybody,
but I had a secret worry
that I wouldn't love this adopted baby
like I love my Daisy, whom I carried.
But I'm telling you, when
I picked that child up
and put her in my arms,
the love is exactly the same.
There is not a bit of
difference in the love
for the baby that I carried and the baby
that God gave us through adoption.
It's exactly the same.
- I've actually heard several
people say that with adoption,
that it was specifically the mothers
that were always worried.
They were like, "I'm just
worried, because you know,
I had this other child in me,"
- Yeah.
- and they always say the same thing.
They say it's identical.
- Yeah.
- That's a beautiful thing.
So does your Dolly have
the kick-butt attitude
of Dolly Parton?
(audience laughs)
(Kimberly laughs)
- She's so much fun, yes.
It was my husband's
idea to name her Dolly,
which I'm so happy he thought of that.
It was perfect.
But she's funny, she's outgoing,
she's delightfully sassy,
you know, she's got the
perfect little amount of sass
and so much fun.
And we got to meet,
those are the pictures,
we got to meet the Dolly.
- Oh my god.
- And she was just so precious
about my little Dolly,
and I've seen her since,
and she always is just the sweetest.
We love that woman.
- You're, oh, Dolly,
yeah, Dolly Parton is
such an amazing woman.
And so sweet.
Your daughter, Dolly's gonna freak out
when she's older at
those pictures (laughs).
- Yeah, totally (laughs).
- Like, I'm like, I want
those pictures, like (laughs),
that's amazing.
- You know what happened,
when my Dolly met the Dolly,
she kept putting her hands somewhere,
in a particular place.
(Kelly laughs)
(Kimberly laughs)
- It must be a baby thing though.
My kids were like that.
My girl and my boy.
They both kept touching people's
I go, "You can't touch people's boobs."
Like you gotta lay off.
(Zachary laughs)
Like, it's like, they always kept trying,
and I'm like, I don't know,
they look like pillows
I guess, I don't know to a baby,
I don't know.
- I know.
- But they, it was, yeah,
then you feel awkward when you're the mom.
You're like, "They never do that."
(group laughs)
So you've met Dolly, right?
Dolly Parton.
- I have yeah, yeah.
- Is it awesome?
- It was amazing.
We were both guests on a talk show,
and we were in the green room area.
She was about to go on.
I had just come off stage.
So I didn't want to get, you know,
I was respectful of her space.
But she just went like that
across the green room,
(audience laughs)
and I was like,
"What?", like,
- Stop.
- so, I had this incredible
interaction with her.
I didn't take a picture,
which I feel like,
I'm not big on like, "Can
we take a picture?", like,
- I don't like bothering people either.
- but that's one person
that I've met in my life
where I'm like, "Why didn't I just
pull out my phone?"
- I know,
but that's such a cool experience.
Of course she did this
from far away.
- I love the memory.
The memory is enough,
- That's amazing.
- and just that image of
her being so thoughtful
and so generous.
- Oh, she's so kind.
Agreed.
- She's amazing.
- Well, Kimberly's book is
called "A Dolly for Christmas".
It's out right now,
y'all gotta check it out.